tres días de comicios legislativos en
rusia en los que el desgastado partido
del kremlin rusia unida busca una nueva
mayoría en la duma o cámara baja del
parlamento en la víspera electoral el
mandatario ruso con más de dos décadas
en el poder animó a sus ciudadanos a
acudir a las urnas
queridos amigos les pido que participen
en las próximas elecciones elijan
cualquier día conveniente para ustedes a
partir del 17 de septiembre vayan a los
colegios electorales o participen con el
voto electrónico y louis suite el mayor
significado de las elecciones es en
primer lugar la expresión de la voluntad
del pueblo ruso como principal fuente de
poder la aplicación de los derechos
constitucionales de los ciudadanos para
determinar un mayor desarrollo del país
que a todos nos gustaría ver soberano y
próspero y buquebus en estas elecciones
se eligen a los 450 diputados que
conformarán la nueva duma estatal
durante los próximos 5 años de los 32
partidos iniciales del comité electoral
central sólo registró 14 muchos
candidatos opositores fueron excluidos
de las listas y el principal detractor
alexéi navalni esta red en una prisión
en siberia pese a que los últimos años
la crisis de kobe 19 o la corrupción han
pasado factura la popularidad de rusia
unida que cuenta con menos de 30 por
ciento de intención de voto hay pocas
posibilidades de un resultado
desfavorable para el partido oficialista
el gobierno ruso solía fingir que
tenemos un estado democrático y
procedimientos que imitan la democracia
ahora solo hay procedimientos sin ningún
intento de ser democráticos
a los aliados de naval ni han estado los
rusos a votar por los comunistas pero
los tres principales partidos del
comunista liberal democrático de rusia y
una rusia justa por la verdad no
alcanzan el 5 por ciento de los votos
para desafiar al kremlin